[Music]
all right it's time once again for the
matinee show this is matinee episode 74
we actually saw it three movies in the
theater this week we haven't done that
for a really long time yeah and then
we're all good they were all pretty good
yeah we're actually all fairly decent um
you know what I mean it's but this
probably won't happen again for a while
because I don't think like this upcoming
week I'm not sure there's a lot of [ __ ]
coming out in the theater a lot of new
[ __ ] and Plus um I think on the next
show I want to review color out of space
because we pre-ordered the blu-ray and
it should be arriving early next week so
that'll probably be at least one of the
ones that we do and I don't give a [ __ ]
about pandemics though man I'm gonna see
James Bond in theatres well yeah you
know talk about if I have to wear a
goddamn mask I'm gonna see James Bond in
theatres that's a 1 is that April I
don't know yeah that's April yeah middle
the [ __ ] Omega man and I got a mass
conscious Omega Man world yeah so we
actually did see yeah three movies in
the theater this week so we're gonna
start out with Sonic the Hedgehog yeah
now this is very funny because I mean
this was like a huge thing because
obviously I remember seeing a trailer
for this movie like way back last year
sometime and I didn't really think
anything about it others often other
than why are they making a movie out of
that whatever but then everybody I found
out that everybody had flipped out about
how weird the character design is
because apparently the movie was
supposed to come out last November but
because everybody had such a [ __ ]
freaked out about how weird the
character look and it did look 30 weird
weird that actually like the [ __ ]
production company Sony or whoever it
was they actually spent an extra five
million dollars at least to go back and
redesign the whole entire character and
the time that it takes to do it yeah and
so like it got pushed back to this
former Valentine's Day
yeah it paid dividends though they did
that I did though and actually to the
Damned fans yeah I think the problem was
they were trying to look too realistic
well they yeah they said that the
original conception for the concept was
that or the character was they wanted it
to look like like Ted for Bette talking
teddy bear maybe
who was kind of a more realistic looking
teddy bear but was like a CGI character
and people were like you know Sonic is a
videogame character and why don't you
make him look like a videogame character
in a realistic universe rather than
trying to make him look realistic
because it just looked really strange
and like uncanny valley so props to them
for actually going back and fixing some
[ __ ] made everybody complained and it
actually turned out like you said a lot
better for them because this movie seems
to be making a lot of money and even
critic reviews are you know mixed to
positive most people saying it's a
perfectly fine it's a family movie it's
you know it's kind of like a kid movie
um same tone as detective Pikachu from
last year but I liked this a lot better
than detective Pikachu just because I'm
more familiar with Sonic as a character
than I am with I'm not real familiar
with like Pokemon the Pokemon universe
so you know I actually played some of
the Sonic games back in the 90s which is
funny because I was reading a [ __ ]
article about this movie on Wikipedia
what I didn't realize this movie has
been in production or they've been
wanting to make it since 1994 yeah it
makes sense they had like this all
because that's kind of when the Sonic's
heyday was oh my gosh in it and I was
thinking you know I was like yeah I
remember this character II nice played
all these video games yeah I had Sega
yeah I did too
and Sonic was kind of like when you wave
was drawn he was an updated Japanese
version added Mickey Mouse that's
basically she had Mickey Mouse but you
don't really know what his carrot what
his personality's like he doesn't talk
in the video games you just fighting
this mr. Robotnik guy and when you see
them when you see the the movie starts
to kind of make sense at first I kind of
thought the character was a little too
annoying he's a little bit more like a
teenage boy too much I thought but then
as it went on it started to make more
sense of why he was like that I kind of
expected him to be kind of like a
character a few words because I wasn't
used to seeing him talk yeah pretty
quick I'm like okay I see what I see
where they're going with this it was a
very it's an update
did cut cooler version of Mickey Mouse
keys got phased man Mickey Mouse's
not really that cool no Mickey Mouse is
very cool that's true
sonic was cool you know I thought I
thought he's kind of a cooler version of
that and as I'm watching it I was like
why didn't they come out with this movie
a long time ago back in the 90s when
Sega was still they wanted to because
the merchandising potential is huge yeah
because the drawing of it looks pretty
cool I think of drawing a Songz head you
know coming out of a logo I think it
looks better than Mickey Mouse actually
yeah you know just my opinion I think
Mickey Mouse is kind of kind of soft
looking you know kind of SOI but sonic
was kind of neat he's got the little
clicking jagged hair and tennis shoes
big old tennis shoes and you know I just
I liked the movie I thought the movie
was satisfying as a satisfying family
film there's a little bit of everything
in it
it definitely Harry [ __ ] knocks it
out yeah he kind of stole the movie I
want to say um well the thing about it
like I said you know since they had been
considering making this movie since the
90s and it just never happened because
you know the video game adaptation
movies that were coming out in the 90s
like [ __ ] Super Mario Brothers and
like Street Fighter and stuff like that
didn't do very well so I guess the plans
were scrapped until like 2013 and then
they started like talking about doing it
again so in a lot of ways this seems
like a 90s throwback and like you said
the thing about Sonic's character now I
I think I only played like the first
Sonic the Hedgehog like Sega game that
came out now apparently there were a lot
of other ones and they might still be
making him I'm not really sure yeah they
would given him they would give a shout
outs to all of them just yet camera
angles and certain things that happened
but yeah so what I was gonna say was
that I think in some of the later
iterations he might have talked or he
might have had more of a personality
they didn't know because it does seem
like and I believe and please correct me
if I'm wrong I believe that there was an
animated show of Sonic the Hedgehog for
a little while maybe back in the
to late 90s unless I'm like having a
favor dream but I thought seem to
remember that so I do feel like the
sonic character because in the 90s like
all the characters were like smartass
teenagers yeah so in that sense the way
that they did Sunday more sense it does
actually make more sense he's not like a
real annoying like no he's like a
coked-out little teenage boy you know
yeah he's actually yeah he's kind of
charming it took me a while like to get
into his character because like he said
I wasn't really expecting it but you
know he's not so much he's not like an
[ __ ] like Bart Simpson is he's more
like like you said he's real coked up
which makes sense because you know he
runs really fast and you would think so
he does everything quickly and [ __ ] like
that so basically what they did was they
made this essentially it's a superhero
movie but it's also kind of like a buddy
road trip type of movie and it's also an
alien movie he's an alien from another
dimension basically yeah which i think
was a good way of doing it's how you
explain him and I think it's cool too
that they made it where because I think
when I first saw and I saw a couple of
the reviews of this to where I think
people were from the trailers or maybe
expecting it to be like oh he's an alien
and he it's like a fish out of water
type story but it's not really like that
because he's been on earth for a long
time yeah but just nobody really knows
about him he grew up here yeah like he
like he got sent here because you know
someone was like trying to get his
powers and so he got sent to earth you
know to this kind of small town so there
so there's kind of like this charming
thing where it's not so much you know he
knows about earth it's just that he
can't show himself to anybody because
he's always like in danger of somebody
taking his power so he feels very
isolated because all he can do is he
lives in this small town and he loves it
and he loves all the people in it but
nobody knows that he exists like he's
just kind of like watching them from
afar and wishing that he could be part
of it so I feel like the whole theme of
this is him trying to find like a
connection or him trying to find
friendship is kind of like the main
point of the movie the movie also
explains sonic rings and why sonic needs
rings yeah what they also gave a lot
or the character to mr. Robotnik doctor
or dr. Robotnik and you know he's kind
of like the villain in the games in the
games he's always coming up with these
damn robots and machines and he's a
government contractor you know he's
hired to figure out you know this alien
electromagnetic pulse that had happened
but Jim Carrey knocks it out of the park
I mean he channels he channels that
character from from The Fray from the
Friday's F Rico he reminded me very much
of that
I forgot that I forgot that I was
watching Jim Carrey I thought I was
watching Jeffrey Combs
yeah he demeaned there's a couple times
where he got all uh I'll just all Jim
Carrey II yeah I know he could dance and
[ __ ] the Rope the Robotnik outfit was
[ __ ] his outfit was awesome of the
good clothes that he had on yeah and it
covered all the bases the different
mustaches that you saw Robotnik with you
know in the video games and his
technology the drones and the vehicles
and even some of the every time he has a
confrontation with Sonic it looks like a
kind of like a boss fight we're very
reminiscent of a boss fight in an old
platformer video game it's pretty cool
very good and there's definitely gonna
be a sequel it sets it up for a sequel
to in I'm not like a spoil anything
yeah don't spoil it because there's a
very well there's like a watch there's a
sequence there was it like after the
credits but then there's more and then
there's another very very short yeah
little thing that's kind of like leading
up until the next thing and I'm like and
you know if you if you've ever played
the games it pays homage to the games I
mean yeah exactly
I mean I'm like I said it's set in the
real world it's set in a really small
town in Montana even though I think it
was filmed in Vancouver probably
everything is nowadays but um you know
so there's kind of a bowl thing where
it's like you know small town versus
thing you know it's it's a kids movie
kind of so I feel like there's some
stuff you know it's kind of like some
plot holy type of stuff like he needs
the cop to like take him to San
Francisco even though he could get a map
or I don't know but whatever it's like
it's not really that big a deal I think
his whole thing was he wanted to like
hang out yeah he wanted to hang out with
cuz he like admired him so much and I so
I guess he like took that opportunity
when going kind of a father figure
yeah and I feel like there was that too
and I want to say too that I was gonna
say about Jim Carrey I'm not um I like
Jim Carrey in his dramatic roles he was
great and like you know eternal sunshine
and you know Truman Show and stuff like
that some of his comedic roles are like
especially as old ones the ones he's
known for like Ace Ventura and the masks
and stuff like that it's like that gets
old very quickly for me all the cocaine
inspires yeah it's like you know what I
mean so that kind of stuff going it is
very annoying so I can only take that
for a few but this one I think he hit he
struck a perfect balance because he's
he's not like he's over the top but it's
not like wacky zany like look I'm
talking out of my [ __ ] or anything
like that it's like you said it was very
Jeffrey Combs ish where he's also kind
of creepy and sinister but over the top
at the same time I mean and me yeah but
he's also like kind of funny right and
sometimes he's just insane he's a madman
yeah and I think he's just like a good
Jeffrey Combs care it is it's very much
like that and it remind it was funny
that you said that like after week
that's exactly what I was thinking of
from the frighteners that's exactly what
I was thinking of like in some of
particularly like the way he interacted
was like his henchmen and like his
little dance jumper like a freaky stuff
so he really does steal the movie um but
this was like a surprisingly you know I
considering when I saw the trailer like
a long time ago and I didn't even hardly
think that much about it I was like
laughs whatever that looks like it's
gonna be dumb or whatever but it
actually turned out it's kind of like a
sweet entertaining it's a pretty fun
[ __ ] movie and it's like you know you
can take the kids to see a kids will
probably [ __ ] love it it's just like
a really adorable [ __ ] I'm 50 and played
those games when I was you know in the
army everybody played that shitty Weezer
[ __ ] play Sonic and the barracks
Beach of his ass is behind Sonic
and I like that game yeah yeah it was
pretty original one yeah and yeah you
know I would have been happy to pay to
see this movie yeah yeah like a lot of
people that are really into I was
watching Chris stuckman reviewed it and
he's kind of like a bigger like I said I
played the first game but I'm not like a
huge fan of like the character of the
franchise like that but he was kind of
coming at it from he had played like all
of the games and he was kind of a fan of
the character and he ended up really
liking the movie um although he made a
suggestion that I somebody needs to get
on board with this somebody needs to
make a Metroid maybe yeah while they're
doing video game movies I would watch
the NEXRAD be cool cuz that was one of
my favorite link would be cool yeah I
feel look have they tried to make any
Zelda movies I feel like they maybe have
probably did probably but this was a
good movie it's it's a feel-good movie a
movie for all family for the whole
family there's just it's just a it's
just a fun adventure it's just a fun
like escapist yeah road trip honey pure
escapism if you need to [ __ ] just get
away from the real world you can just
watch this yeah you know perfectly
perfectly fun movies yeah
you
alright next maybe we checked out in the
theater this week was Fantasy Island oh
yeah Balam houses Fantasy Island if you
would rather now uh this one actually
came out a week or two ago we were gonna
see it last week and then we just didn't
get around to it
in the meantime like I said I try not to
watch like other people's reviews until
after I've seen the movie but I had been
hearing through the grapevine that a lot
of people were really [ __ ] on this
movie and I saw that on IMDB or [ __ ]
Rotten Tomatoes or whatever that's like
10 percent something like that so
they're tripping well we decided we were
gonna go see Invisible Man anyway which
is the one we're gonna review next so he
said well you know might as well we'll
just go see this one before that one you
know once we'll make an evening of it so
we decided to go see it so I was
expecting this to be I thought a vicious
an orphanage fire I mean seriously I I
expected this to be like really really
bad now don't get me wrong it's not a
great movie but it's a perfectly I don't
know if I'd ever watch it again or like
buy it or anything like that but it's
not a movie that be taken serious no
it's not it's an entertainment movie
it's it's basically adventure horror
comedy well it kind of tries to be
everything right way everything here's
the thing like I feel like I first
started seeing trailers for this like
several months ago cuz man they put a
trailer for this in front of like every
single movie that we saw and I was like
well the trailer I was like well that
looks dumb but it's like I'm I'm kind of
intrigued by the premise because you
know we grew up in the 70s Saturday
nights you watched Love Boat and then
Fantasy Island and then [ __ ] Saturday
Night Live man so I feel like Fantasy
Island had the potential I'm like yeah
they could totally go horror with that
because I remember I don't remember like
a huge amount of the episodes but I do
remember some of them had a supernatural
element yeah cuz wasn't there one with
like a werewolf and wasn't there with
like a ventriloquist dummy and Schilling
I haven't seen it in a long time but
this is what I can tell you based on
memory of the original series
mysterious [ __ ] would happen it was
never explained yeah it was never
explained was this done by some college
go trickery or was it magic and I
remember being led to believe that there
was some soup paranormal [ __ ] going on
yeah Fantasy Island and that it was
paranormal but they kind of pretended
and they told the guests that it was
kind of technological fakery and ashes
and stuff but there's too much stuff
that it happened over over the over the
course of that whole that's always cuz
the show was on for like [ __ ] six or
seven years I think right and you know
they were just trying to tell a bunch of
morality tales and yeah that should
happen and overtime you go wait this is
[ __ ] reducing land it's fantasy
island yeah all right kind of like in
the way and they were making it up as
they were going along but it worked out
kind of like in England yeah the series
the prisoner yeah I don't think they
were making that up as they were going
along just bunch of weird [ __ ] I don't
know that stuff in that series was never
ultimately never exploit fantasy I'm was
kind of like that it was a bunch of
individual morality tales for three or
four of them going on in each episode
and the [ __ ] went on forever and so much
stuff happened on that island it's not
possible that's what I'm saying so
that's why that's why I'm saying when I
saw the trailer I was like even though
the movie itself looked dumb I was like
I like that concept because I remember
Fantasy Island and I was like the thing
about the original TV show that was kind
of genius other than Ricardo Montalban
being in it and he was like kicked ass
that was like the man but but it's it's
a really good premise because you can
essentially go any shanwa you want to go
with it you can have whatever guests are
you can do whatever you want so it's
essentially like an anthology show right
um with horror elements sci-fi elements
you can do whatever you want and it's
all like in the context of that and now
that I'm saying that somebody needs to
do like a [ __ ] anthology series of
[ __ ] fantasy island instead of this
movie which I like I said this movie
it's not terrible but I feel like um
that I feel like the the concept could
have been done a bit better now one
thing I will say is that the original TV
show
they never explained how fantasy haven't
worked this movie it does they kind of
do and I wish they hadn't done that what
they did was with this is that this is
basically an origin story yeah other
like a prequel it's like a prequel to a
rebooted yeah
Fantasy Island which you know who are
they gonna get to fill Ricardo
montalban's shoes to the guy that they
got being Roark Michael Payne yeah yeah
yeah he did a great job but there's a
certain there was a certain physicality
to [ __ ] Ricardo Montalban you know
what I mean he was kind of like he was
kind of like a Mexican Chris Reeves or
maybe like the Mexican Marlon Brando or
something you know I mean he he had a
character in a physicality to him
we had some mystery to him yeah he was
so Tarek and it almost kind of like a
James Bond yeah - yeah and you know when
he when he played con a lot of people
thought that was somehow prosthetic
snowman that was all man well because we
shoot his chest on some of the fans yeah
it was he was in a good shape the guy
that they got like I said it's a it's a
prequel yeah maybe he transforms slowly
once he becomes the Roark the mr. Roark
that you knew from the series because
actually it what you saw in the series
in this universe hasn't happened yet it
does seem like it because yeah because
it has to do with the characters and
then the way the order that they appear
yeah all right
there's an this is kinda like in a way
mr. Rourke's origin story yeah sorta
because I think this is the the first
batch of guests or some of the very
first batches of guests before they
worked all the kinks down before they
worked on the case out can't happen like
death that's a pretty big kick yeah that
was that's the difference in the
original and in the TV series no one
ever got hurt
well yeah but it was network TV I mean
what are you gonna do you can kill
people off like and this one you can get
killed on Fantasy Island yeah all right
so
it's not and then sometimes the Dead
come back to life there's Xabi type
things happening yeah the island itself
is there's a paranormal force on the
island and that's all kind it's kind of
explained not really explained it shows
it to you but they don't really say well
yeah yeah they didn't say where it came
from but they didn't explain how there's
an ancient temples and ruins is right
and caves and stuff now it's like here's
one thing like I said now Michael Payne
yeah I like him as an actor I don't know
like he said I feel like someone else
might have made a better work like I was
looking at some other reviews and like
some people recommend it like Benedict
Cumberbatch or maybe Benicio del Toro he
would've been Antonio Banderas somebody
yeah yeah a couple people recommended
that yeah was like a bit more gravitas
somebody like a bit bigger like a big
tall he had to be real any kind of real
suave even though this guy Pena doesn't
pretty good job yeah I still think
Antonio Banderas is close what you need
somebody with some Menace I feel like I
feel like Ricardo Montalban he came
across as charming but also like he
would like whip your ass if you like
cross him yeah you weren't really sure
whether he was God or a devil or a demon
they reboot I totally forgot about this
but they rebooted the series in 1998 and
Malcolm McDowell played mr. Rourke at
work and yeah and I feel like that work
too because Malcolm McDowell always
comes across slightly like really like
sinister like a crazy person kind of and
that's like a compliment so I feel like
that would have were I don't think I saw
the reboot but I totally forgot about it
so I was reading about this but I think
the problem with this it's like if they
were going to lean into Fantasy Island
as a horror concept which I'm behind
that and I feel like maybe the whole
reason that they wanted to do it was
because what last year the year before
when they took the banana splits that TV
show and made that into like a slasher
movie which I haven't seen it but I you
know like some people like a lot of
people seem to have aided it but you
know I'm not gonna judge so I feel like
that's probably where they're coming
from with this even though I think
Fantasy Island is a better property to
do that with because it already had like
a little bit of a Twilight Zone
kind of aspect to it yeah I wish they
had leaned a little harder into the
horror it seems like this one you know
one of the stories was pretty much
basically a straight-up horror story
that was like Lucy Hales you know thing
where she wanted to get revenge on her
bullies that was like a torture porn
type of thing but the rest of them the
other ones there was one that was kind
of like action II there was one that was
kind of like you know like a bro frat
party thing that kind of goes into like
a crime direction the other one was just
like a straight-up melodrama that ended
up later having like a little bit of a
thriller aspect or like a or like a
horror aspect so I feel like it would
have been cooler if like all of the
stories had been horror related yeah but
they all started to intertwine they did
which I likes that a run at each other
and then there was flips involved it's a
convoluted story it is very convoluted
but you I was just watching it having a
good time and not really taking anything
seriously I was just along for the ride
I I actually enjoyed the movie yeah I
did as well there was some things that I
would have changed but you know what you
could build on this movie you could make
a serie you can make a series or a
sequel to this with Pena and everything
that it would work yeah but you can
tweak it to make it even better to even
maybe compliment the original series a
little bit more yeah although I do say
that this did kind of capture the tone
of your average Fantasy Island episode
it did kind of like the more I thought
about it
Tom Munich relief cuz always yeah it's a
TV show it was a variety show did it's
like some of them were like funny and
campy and like some of them were kinda
creepy and like Twilight Zone ish
it's about what the average episode was
like yeah so the schizo tone of this is
not as far off from the original show I
guess as they could now they probably
will like they said like I said like you
said they did set up like a sequel you
couldn't see this and I'm sure they will
probably make one despite all the [ __ ]
that this movie is getting it only costs
7 million
make it and it's already made 35 million
oh yeah oh it's already like that more
than three times it was that cheap so
well it's Blum House and blue houses big
thing is they want to make horror movies
for as cheaply as possible because
horror movies tend to make a lot but
even though they don't have to make like
four hundred million dollars you know to
make twice their money back you know
what I mean so blunt house I mean they
have their kind of hit or miss I mean
they made some great [ __ ] obviously they
made get out
they made Invisible Man which the next
ones I'm gonna talk about but they've
also made some kind of crappy you know
they made like [ __ ] and and the guy
that directed this Jeff Ludlow I think
his name is
he also made truth or truth or dare
which was which kind of sucked I have to
admit I think Lucy Hale was in that to
the same actress but I think because I
was expecting this to be terrible um
maybe that's how I should go into every
movie because because I actually thought
I was at low expectations I did too I
just thought it was gonna be dumb and
[ __ ] and it is dumb as [ __ ] but it was
fun though it was an enjoyable is kind
of fun like I said the third act I like
that it went more horror I like that
Michael Rooker was in it although you
needed more screen time he wasn't really
in it but it was still work but like the
guy who played the [ __ ] Russian
terrorist or the Russian gang back yeah
that guy was Dan I like there was good
here's another thing there was good
acting in it yeah there was everybody
did a good job everybody did the role
that they were supposed to do yeah goofy
comedic guys everything is fine yeah
very night at the Roxbury yeah that was
the tone and that was the way the
television series was and that's they
did it you could run it just like this
what I would do for part two and seeing
as it made that much already said yeah
they're gonna make another one I'm sure
they will yeah let me if it did that
well they'll make a note and then you
see streaming in blu-ray haven't come
out yet it'll make it a little bit more
with that probably streaming it'll
probably do what real well because I
feel like sometimes the worst a movie
gets reviewed like the more people want
to see it just because they want to see
what a garbage fire it is this movie is
not that but it's not if this one is not
nearly as bad as I was expecting like I
said it
it's not [ __ ] you know great it's
just like a dumb horror movie it's it's
a lot better than truth or dare Jeff
Pablo's other movies it was a lot better
than some of Blum House's other movies
like the gallows and stuff like that
which is pretty terrible um it looked
kind of cheap other than like the island
locations look really nice yeah they
shot it in Fiji and also it's pg-13 it's
perfect if I mean if they're gonna do I
wish though like I said if they do a
sequel I wish they would make it a
hard-r like make it more like a slasher
movie because this one it just seemed
like do you know why this one is like I
wouldn't even call this you in a horror
movie it's exactly it'll do better on
streaming I know Xbox fits with this
pg-13 people I think I think you'll have
more action like just like I was gonna
say Harlequin didn't need to be are that
have been dead or better is it it
probably would have done better as a
pg-13 da actually have a pg-13 version
of it out already I heard what they
could what they might be able to do like
you know in regards to this one and
maybe like in some other of blum houses
like pg-13 horror franchises is maybe
they could do a pg-13 movie like for the
theaters and then have an R version that
comes out or have a blu-ray with both
versions on it
yeah um it's probably that seams in
Tibet yeah that has like all the Goron's
and then out ya know that probably
better what I what I would do if in the
sequel you could run that same cast you
know or pretty much especially the same
mr. Rourke I probably would like get pan
you kind of trimmed down and [ __ ]
bulked up a little bit get him and put
him in a nice tailored white suit and
because he had the mannerisms he did
he'd do the mannerisms he just needed to
be I think more physically fit looking
like more imposing more yeah exactly he
seems a little too friendly well not for
a minister part of the friendliness of
him is that he's he's he's not fat but
he's a little he's a little plump yeah
you know I mean he needs to bring in the
waist a little bit maybe pump up the
shoulders and the arms a little bit put
him in a nice tailored suit to kind of
get that James Bond profile you know how
yeah you know how Craig looks like in a
suit if you look back dad in a way
so if I've accepted more as the worker
that we knew from TV yeah but you could
say well this is his origin story cuz
remember that's kind of how I took it
because he had his own issues to Rourke
was also one of the [ __ ] ya fantasy
albums victims he could put it that way
yeah and if they and if they continued
with and like you said the story is kind
of convoluted but if they kind of
continue along this way with the rules
that they set up as kind of confused and
all over the place as they are they
could kind of tighten that up some and
you know so I could see there is
potential there for people to
shape-shift you know I'm saying yeah and
I think I think we need to see it a
sleeker pan yeah yeah you know I mean
the way Roarke was really sleek and and
and then and and and going with the
full-blown television version of mr.
Roarke and act and I would bias I would
buy a sequel so then the second one to
be should be straight-up horror and then
the third one should also be horror but
it should be a fantasy island Love Boat
cross Okada yeah we could do that too
with a total horror movie and notation
gory ER is like go for it do this whole
review have not mentioned tattoo we're
gonna we're gonna leave that alone
that's that's that's a seat that's a
spoiler yeah okay that's just for that
yeah so we're not gonna so I was
watching the whole thing I was like what
the [ __ ] are they gonna do it where the
[ __ ] is tattoo it's eventually resolved
it yeah it gets resolved like yeah this
is kind of like a prequel so three equal
you know what I mean so um you know what
I mean it's this is just I know the
reviews are bad and I know it's like but
this movie does have a lot of problems
but it's not a bad movie but I didn't
[ __ ] stinkers man I had a good time
yeah i dissing I wasn't bored it's like
well if it was a little like I said was
a little bit confusing I think they
needed to like tighten up like the rules
of the island yeah because some of the
stuff at the eggs or like we were like
I'm they're saying all this I'm like
wait what is going on
oh we can do this now like you know so I
feel like they need to like sweep that
like mop that up a little bit just
because I was confused about exactly I
just gave up I'm like just watching it
and enjoying it and the twist at the end
which I'm not gonna spoil but the twist
at the end was a little unbelievable
like and again kind of convoluted but
that's you know it wasn't like a deal
breaker weena certainly seen way worse
oh yeah yeah and this one was you know
it was a totally fun like afternoon now
what I play what I pay 15 dollars to see
this in [ __ ] Dolby theater I'm gonna
say no yeah I we didn't pay to see it
I mean we did cuz we have a MC stuff we
got ACM stuff Salus when you see three
movies a week a week crazy so what I
want like I got ripped off like I should
have selected him another booth [ __ ] no
if I didn't have if I had time to burn
I'd spent 6 bucks on this yeah you could
see it like on a like on a Tuesday when
it was five dollars yeah whatever
yeah but it's like I don't feel like we
wasted like I don't like oh god that's
two hours I'll never get back it wasn't
like that it's like I had a totally fine
time ah yeah and uh you know this might
be a we'd movie if you if you if you
were some weed it was probably even
better it's kind of there's certain
elements of like Temple of Doom from
frickin Raiders when I was a kid was
over like just sat there watch that [ __ ]
again I can see how we'd would
dramatically improve the yeah wouldn't
dramatically improve this movie yeah I
feel like it would but yeah so seriously
we can get us hung up in things as much
you just roll with it you know well I
was try try not to do that anyway
because like a lot of times the tone of
the movie was whether it was telling you
that it was not to be - yeah they're
just like don't worry about it and and I
wasn't like I usually won't while I'm
watching movies like unless something's
really egregious like so egregious that
it like takes me out of like what the
[ __ ] happened there you know what I mean
so nothing was that bad now when I
thought about it later I was like well
wait a minute what about like yeah the
other thing but while I was watching it
I was
really said I wasn't really concerned
about it was just like why don't you
we're not concerned about it watching it
on television either right sex and
that's what that's exactly what they did
that was your Saturday night like in the
late 70s and early 80s you watched love
but I didn't like love but I liked
fantasy I was better in love though but
I'd sit with my grandma like on that
yeah well love boat just seemed like
just so love come on you know I was what
seven I start singing the song I used to
know all the lyrics I read then what's
the song is over you know I don't mean
the grass have you shown up on okay yeah
yeah time to check out well I'd like to
watch the beginning because then you got
to see like what guest stars were on
there but then I can't remember anything
yeah I don't know anything after that so
like I said it didn't go I was you
didn't go in a horror direction so it so
it kind of lost my head I was young but
I wasn't that young I was old enough to
be attracted about him [ __ ] cute
women it would show up on a show well
yeah yeah I feel like a lot of people
remember that they had that girl that
worked on the [ __ ] boat with the
[ __ ] damn Dorothy Hamill here
yeah yeah yeah was her name Julie yeah
you're crazy whatever
what's that she was in that [ __ ]
movie that we [ __ ] she was an
airplane wasn't she I think I don't know
yeah anyway so as [ __ ] on as this movie
is getting it's actually I didn't think
it was as bad as everyone was saying
it's certainly not great it's pretty
dumb but if you go into it with that and
just kind of turn your basic
entertainment movie it's just like
entertaining yeah and like I got more
than she liked it I think you probably
did I like I didn't find it I didn't
mind it but I expected it to like suck
out loud so I was like oh that wasn't
all that bad
I enjoyed and like I said I liked it
better than [ __ ] truth or dare
because I thought the [ __ ] was [ __ ]
tell you so I tell you what if they make
it if they make a sequel I'll probably
go see that's it yeah it's see that too
I'd see that especially if they go more
in a horror direction yes I think they I
think that I think that was what I
wanted it to go more horror and not have
just like one thread that was horror and
all the other ones for kind of other
genres you know what I mean I liked it I
thought it was just a carefree enjoyable
movie
okay
[Laughter]
you
all right so the third one we saw this
week this is another one from Blum House
productions this was the Invisible Man
this is another Blum Blum house they
distributed it yeah okay it was a good
movie
this one this is easily I think this is
one of my favorite movies that I've seen
so far this year this one is like it's
funny to me because it I guess it didn't
really occur to me until after I'd seen
the trailer a couple of times but this
was original in 2016 or whatever it was
that they were trying to like Universal
was trying to get that dark universe
thing off the ground yeah Universal
Monsters and they made which is a great
idea in theory but then they made the
mommy with Tom Cruise and it's like it
didn't it made money but it didn't make
as much as they were expecting and like
the critics hated it and all the
suggesting so yes so they kind of
scrapped the whole idea of doing that
however they did still want to make cuz
didn't I think they made Dracula untold
and some other ones too that was pretty
good yeah which was okay but I think it
didn't do very much so I think what
they're planning on doing now is they're
still planning on rebooting some of
these monster movies but they're not
gonna be interconnected like initially
they were all gonna be part of the same
like shared universe like Marvel but
yeah they decided just not to do that
they said we're still gonna do that but
we just wanted to be like standalone I
heard they were supposed to make Bride
of Frankenstein last year but I guess
that never happened
so this one was actually one of the ones
that was initially supposed to be in
there interconnected universe but they
decided you know what [ __ ] it we're just
gonna do it's like gonna be a whole
different thing and it's gonna be its
own thing so now this was directed by
Leigh Whannell who did SAW he did
upgrade so yes so he's done like a bunch
of really insidious which was also very
good so he kind of took this and did
something really cool with it
now it's loosely adapted from you know
like the original movies that they made
back in the 30 like with Claude Rains
and stuff like that which is based on
the HG Wells novel basically about a
it's a mad scientist-type movie but this
one is more we still at point of view
it's not from his point of view which is
the one thing that makes it really
interesting
to me because even though I don't think
it deviates as I mean deviates from the
source material but not as much as it
seemed it because I feel like in their
original novel and in the original
movies like with Claude Rains and stuff
like that and even in like Holloman with
Kevin Bacon I feel like the dude was
always a dick
even before he discerned because his
whole reason for wanting to be invisible
was ooh look at all the [ __ ] I could get
away with cos nobody would see me and I
think even in the original book the
whole point of HG Wells book was that
what would people do if they didn't have
other people watching or like keeping
them in line you know what I mean so I
feel like that's kind of cool that they
took this but then they kind of flipped
it so that the you know the point of
view was from one of his victims rather
than him stories about this chick she
leaves her boyfriend her boyfriends this
gazillionaire genius and he makes he's
like a contractor for militaries and
governments gays working to make all
different kinds of things and one of the
things that he made was the suit puts
you on it bends it's a predator suit but
it's actually but it's even better than
the predator camouflages it's a perfect
camouflage yeah you can see right
through the person that's bend and light
somehow er excusing it's using weird
cameras and screens not real plausible
but okay fine because they've had
technology has done that kind of stuff
for a long time but it's not effective
because it cast light it's a screen the
screens always cast like even when the
screen is black he's not invisible
anyway she leaves him and he's such a
[ __ ] maniac he's stalking her he's
like a stalking abusive boyfriend who
just can't let the [ __ ] go
and that's when just when the troubles
began yeah I mean he's making her think
that she's crazy she doesn't know about
this suit yeah she finds out later she
didn't know that he he made that and he
destroys her life using this guy thing
and it's sucking but it's [ __ ] cool
in events it starts off kind of like it
there
this one thing that is good about this
movie is that it did not break my 10-15
minute rule I was immediately kind of
pulled into it I was like man okay
so I was in the movie very quickly there
were a couple times where after she left
him she moved a little too much again
got it although that was a really short
time I seem to me like it went on five
ten minutes too long
it can't go refer back to it maybe if I
were to see it again yeah it didn't feel
like was lying to me but see my sense of
time gets kind of stretched out in the
beginning part of a movie sometime I'm
trying to try to add add adjust to the
story I think yeah and five minutes may
seem like 15 to me or yeah to me it
seemed like I mean the opening scenes of
the movie is her sneaking out of her
boyfriend's house trying to get the
funny way she's obviously been planning
this for yeah but when she moved out of
the new roommate and she's moping around
a little too much and it kind of like
okay I got you
and we know it baby you were [ __ ]
abused whatever let's get to this back
to the story already got that it seemed
like it kept trying to reinforce it too
much and I wanted to see what was gonna
happen next I already knew that she was
running from the guy yeah the guy was
bad but anyway it Connor goes in the
direction of a ghost movie yeah and then
it almost kind of seems almost kind of
like The Exorcist and then it almost
seems like a movie about it's sandy and
then he gets into an action movie for a
little bit where he's fighting the cat
it gets really cool it's cool [ __ ] it
shows you what you could do just with a
damn invisibility suit and then
eventually the woman gets her revenge
but yeah it can't spoil anything about
how that [ __ ] goes down the thing that I
liked about this movie and like I said I
really liked a lot of Leigh Whannell
other movies as well and I think he did
a really good job of this because one um
it's not relying on jump scares which I
like oh there was maybe a couple but
they didn't feel like just chief like
who loud noise you know what I mean
anything like that one thing that I
thought was really cool about this
because you're seeing everything from
her perspective you don't see the abuse
she tells somebody about
yeah you don't so the whole thing is
kind of about her the whole theme of it
is like her and her believability
because we know as an audience and she
knows that this [ __ ] [ __ ] is still
alive yeah nobody believes her and he
has an invisibility suit but you know if
your friend told you that you would you
leave her either [ __ ] crazy but we
know and it's like and it's like so it
was freaking me out so bad because it's
like she's just you can tell and like
you can tell that she's trying so hard
like to prove it and to like to get
people to understand like what she's
going through and no one believes that
they just think she's nuts and it's like
look he's dead it's like quit worrying
about it you just have PTSD or whatever
and you're just like because she'd
already she'd been on medication before
like understandably because she'd been
living with this jackal so it's like so
so it's like so frustrating and maybe
it's maybe it's scarier for a woman
because it's just like so frustrating
that it's like everything she knows that
that's what it is but everyone is
questioning her perceptions like it
every single [ __ ] turn and she can't
get anyone to believe her yeah and but
in a way you can see the other side of
it too because like I said if somebody
came to you with that story it's like oh
my dead ex-boyfriend because you know
he's supposed to be dead is still
haunting me only no one can see him you
would think she was crazy too so it's
like you can see both sides of it and
that's what makes it really scary to me
I also really like that the way that
they the way that he shot this movie he
will do these really long like takes
like in a room where she's just like
sitting in a room like staring at the
wall or she like turns around really
slow and then he'll have like this kind
of still shot on like a wall or a
hallway or something like that and he
does that so much that you keep looking
like all around the [ __ ] thing like
thinking where is that [ __ ] I know he's
here somewhere so he's putting you the
director is putting you in the same
position as her because she [ __ ]
knows he's there somewhere and she can't
see him and so he puts the audience in
those shoes because he has these shots
where it's almost kind of like the dudes
in here somewhere it's like if you come
by so you're like looking at all the
corners like see if you can see some
like little
glimpse of Emerson like that because you
know the [ __ ] dude is in there
somewhere so I really like the way he
built tension like that by putting you
in the same position as she is knowing
that he's there but not knowing where he
is yeah what I liked about the movie is
well there was a lot to like about the
movie but one of the main things I liked
about is it showed you how powerful
invisibility would be it really God he
does all kinds of terrible thing do all
kinds of [ __ ] you would never think of
do you see this movie as long as nobody
were to see you yeah oh man yeah yeah so
it was kind of a good examination of how
powerful invisibility is yeah because
when you just think about it kind of
casually like it's like a [ __ ]
superpower but no when you see this
movie and especially the way that he
does because I feel like a lot of the
earlier iterations of the Invisible Man
character that we're done not through
technology but we're done through
essentially like magic or alligator like
a drug or something so I feel like
there's like a lot of stuff where people
are like okay well do I have to walk
around naked can I carry anything or
something like that but this kind of
like gets around that by having like the
technological thing so you don't have to
worry about it's like you know what if I
eat food will they be able to see the
food if I stomach or will they be able
to see like see a bag if I go rob a bank
like they'll see like a little bag
floating visibility's an illusion yeah
you are invisible and it just shows you
what kind of damage you can do how you
can manipulate the environment the legal
systems how you can learn everything if
you even computers how you can
manipulate computers because when you
think it cuz you can look over people's
shoulders yeah they won't know you're
there
right and just the kind of power that
you can get if all the crap that he does
to this poor woman and it's like you
know Elizabeth moss I have to say cuz
I've always loved her other than her
being a Scientologist which okay she's
good thanks but you know I've loved her
ever since I saw her in
you know she's obviously she's
Handmaid's Tale she was in us she is a
great [ __ ] actress and she's really
she always seems to play she's really
good at playing like women in distress
or like women kind of like she's alright
look crazy yeah teetering on the edge
and it's like I think that's kind of
what because this could have been I feel
like the the whole conceit of like an
invisible man and like fighting with an
invisible man that could go drastically
wrong and like kind of turn into like
comedy but it definitely does not at all
we saw it we saw it in the Dolby theatre
the theater was packed everybody liked
it yeah it seems like everyone was like
so riveted like everyone was you could
peer a [ __ ] pin drop and yeah
everybody was like really into I was
into it too because like a couple times
like a revelations that happened the
movies like oh [ __ ] oh oh and I was just
like you know yeah it's it really liked
it it's really like compelling it the
story of the story is very good and a
bunch of stuff happens you didn't see
coming oh yeah I didn't see a lot of
that [ __ ] coming yeah and you know what
I mean
so this one does it's one of the ones
you need to see this month yeah this is
a really really good one and I hope it
does really well and I'm really glad cuz
I you know in theory I loved the idea of
the dark universe but I think it was
kind of stupid to try to make them all
interconnected because that was just
gonna be like every you know things were
gonna be forced into [ __ ] that doesn't
go together and if you like that so I
much prefer the idea like if they're
gonna make like by all means make a
Bride of Frankenstein movie but don't
have it have anything to do with this
movie because how the [ __ ] would you
even do that it just seems like too much
trouble and everything would be like
shoehorn did so I feel like have things
happening at certain time periods yeah
yeah I mean just do [ __ ] like I mean do
[ __ ] like DC does where it's just kind
of like they have the characters and
they just do their own [ __ ] in their own
time period or whatever what I want to
see somebody do and then you might
[ __ ] laugh at me but after see after
seeing DC do Aquaman I want to see a
modern version of the traditional Flash
Gordon I'm talking about with the red
skies I'm surprising closet space pieces
of planets floating there is up and down
in space [ __ ] rocket ship
with dudes out on the wings the right
eye no glass in the windows and here in
the rocket just like just like the 1918
yeah just like the 1981 I thought that
was a beautiful movies looks great on
blu-ray and if you if you watch any of
the old Flash Gordon serials they nailed
that town of the original serial yeah
yeah it's cheesy what's over the
original since well Anna it was also
sexy it had sex and drugs yes before
they had control speck was it was named
the hate code what was it called before
they had any ratings back in the 20s
yeah they hates good the Hays Code that
sir is called if you looked at that
those old sci-fi pre Hays Code stuff it
was racy yeah it looked very modern it
was it looked very very modern you're
like whoa yeah you could get there's
like sex and drugs in in damn kids show
drink this potion you know it's a love
potion
that's [ __ ] drugs any roofie in that
girl yeah well that was it that was him
that was in in [ __ ] Flash Gordon Star
Wars is a [ __ ] copy George Luz Monica
couldn't get the rights of class Gordon
so you just made Star Wars up yeah a
real Star Wars Flash Gordon I want to
see that I feel like people would be a
lot more forgiving of that nowadays
because it's like you can get away with
pretty much anything yeah as long as you
kind of explain your universes like oh
well this is how searching this
university this people like all right
this universe the [ __ ] space is
[ __ ] pink yeah like I said horror
sci-fi fantasy it's like you can get
away with a lot more than you could back
in the day yeah I guess it doesn't have
to be real cloud blue clouds in space
yeah [ __ ] right
but yeah so I really like I really like
that you know Universal decided well we
can still make the monster movies you
know technically but they'll each be
their own thing and and I feel like this
is a really really successful because
they didn't try to make it like The
Mummy they didn't try to make it like a
Marvel movie they just basically made it
it's a horror thriller with a slight
sprinkling of sci-fi just in the sense
of like how he gets to be invisible it's
not like a hard sci-fi that's not it's
just kind of like that's kind of the
mechanism by which it happens
yeah and it's bully
enough that it keeps it grounded in
reality so this is definitely more like
something like sleeping with the enemy
or something like that it you know kind
of like a domestic abuse thriller with a
lot of horror elements a lot of ghost
elements because like I said him being
invisible yes you know he was a ghost
yeah it's you know what I mean so so
there's kind of like a thing where I
mean in the trailers they kind of tell
you that yeah he's just he's not really
dead and he's wearing a suit yeah you
know that you know that you know that
from the jump I the horror comes from
her knowing that and us knowing that but
no one else believing that and thinking
to yourself if you were in that
situation and everyone thought you were
crazy and there was nothing you could do
to convince people otherwise you would
be [ __ ] like harder than anyone had
ever been [ __ ] and so like I felt so
bad like I think sometimes she was
doubting herself well that well and that
was the hell of it too and that's the
same thing that would happen to a real
person in real life because they're
totally being I mean the movie is
essentially gaslighting her yeah he was
trying to get you trying to drive her
crazy make it yeah her think that she
had lost control over her own actions -
yeah and and and that was the [ __ ] of it
- it's bad enough that everyone else
doesn't believe her and that he's like
isolating her he's cutting it cutting
her off for people in various like
horrifying ways but also making her
think maybe I can't trust my own
perceptions and that's like even scarier
so that to me was like very scary and I
think that Elisabeth Moss I mean she
played it so well that you were just
like it was just like heartbreaking like
watching all the terrible [ __ ] that he
was doing and knowing that she couldn't
do anything about it you know what I
mean and so I mean just the way they did
this it's just like it was really creepy
it was just really well done like I said
it's it's a horror movie mostly a
thriller but it's got some horror
elements in it with a little bit of
sci-fi and it's definitely doesn't have
like a bunch of jump scares or a bunch
of crap like that it's just really
atmospheric the way they did like the
shots and you're just like parent making
you paranoid about where the dude is
that [ __ ] like that it was really really
good one of the things I thought was
interesting you know
the guy they don't talk about it they
just show it he is laboratory he was a
he was a contractor yeah trying to sell
basically camouflage to the military
yeah and when I was in the Army in the
90s they showed us a video there was a
demonstration on camouflage and they
would they would show certain things
that they that were out there and one of
the things that are out there they
showed us a damn screen and then the
narrator you know on on the screen says
can you see the man in this I'm like no
then all of a sudden a square moves and
it was was a damn square a book David
had a bulletproof it was a what he
called a Kevlar bulletproof shield about
three - and at 3 feet wide in about 4
feet long with a little tiny hole
through it and a handle in the front of
it was a perfect mere area and if you
dangled it just right when you were in
the woods all that [ __ ] would line up
with the ground
well [ __ ] means couldn't dams missions
have been doing that forever
how do you think they did all those
illusions was like you know the lady
with just the head like in the in the
box and everything that's all done with
Mary yeah he would stand there like that
with this rifle looking through that
little tiny peephole making sure he's
got in the ankle the damn mirror right
so you can't see him yeah until he pops
out they just wanted it was weird they
should you know on screen it worked
yeah I guess in person it probably would
work as long as the angle was right
well yeah but like magicians have done
that for that hundreds of years and you
know we were looking right at it trying
to see it couldn't see it yeah it works
um but yeah oh and fun fact the guy that
plays her abusive ex-boyfriend
Adrian even though he doesn't get much
screen time cuz for most the time he's
invisible is actually played by the same
guy that played I think he played Luke
in haunting a pill house Oliver Jackson
Cohen so there you go he's also very
good in this but like I said this is
kind of Elizabeth Moss's movie the guy
that plays her friend that she's staying
with he is also awesome and elected and
yeah him and the daughter and the
interaction between the three of them is
really good as we saw him in another
movie we yeah was damn it
Aldous Hodge the actor's name is [ __ ]
what was it was just something we saw
recently was that damn it wasn't
Dolomites as my name huh oh [ __ ] I don't
even remember no I'd have to look it up
I can't but yeah I was thinking that too
I was like goddamn what we just saw him
in something else what what but yeah
I'll have to look at this name but yeah
so definitely this is a really really
good if you love thrillers a horror
thriller isn't like particularly one
that's actually kind of scary oh I would
definitely call it a thriller it's more
a thriller it's a it's not like gory or
anything like that but it's it's mainly
a thriller but it has like some really
creepy like go story type [ __ ] in it too
which I really enjoyed but yeah this is
a really really good one so definitely
definitely recommended so go check it
out
[Music]